hidden columns essentially hides columns
based on their importance as the
viewport size gets smaller let's see how
you might do this with a baseball
scoreboard as you can see all the data
is there the short name the long name
and the run scored during each of the
innings plus the final score I'm going
to start small and ask myself what's the
most important information in this case
I'm going to go with the short team name
and the final score I'm going to use
display:none to hide everything else
then as the viewport size gets bigger
let's swap out the full team name and
start showing each of the runs per
inning the biggest problem with hidden
columns is that you're hiding content
from the user what happens if I need to
know how many runs were scored in the
seventh inning if I'm on a device with
the narrow viewport it's just not there
I can't see it
so use this technique with caution and
if possible use abbreviated data instead
of hiding it completely